[Laughter]
hello the Internet we are here with
right there ignore me they're fine right
yeah dan says hi and so do i now we're
gonna do a video about little droplets
of water that land right on the surface
of the water they're not going to come
from high up you're just gonna tip on
and we're gonna see if the droplet kind
of bounces on the surface and then half
goes in or and then bounce it up and
then half beers and again until it's a
really tiny little blob what are you all
about
yeah up through that it's never happened
ever bit crap what you're about so for
this setup I'm using a macro lens 105
mil and phantom flex if you could hold
the drop I can do kinda I'll let you
know exactly where to let it go
all right trying it just to bounce on
the surface okay I see what I see oh all
I said it
how's it yeah you know it
okay what's that oh yeah that's cool oh
oh amazing
that is cold and there's a little
there's a little bubble that bounces off
the big one and goes straight into again
that is really cool I didn't know that
happened at all yeah it kind of a little
it's like half the water in then it
detaches and bounces and then happens
again until this is raising father left
it yeah
still gone now no still just a really
small one though oh that is so cool I
never knew that you didn't know they did
that no the mirror effect really cool as
well
they say someone's throwing a little
ball that gets yellow every time yeah
it's like what have a smaller one when
they give it to a kid and by the time
you told you know yeah free bet you feel
like the right bug the words gonna make
a mug joke but that is in fact not one
that looks like a mug yeah I was
thinking the same thing
yeah you're right oh come on this is
there indeed I'm fired loser oh yeah
yeah all right well I hope you enjoyed
that internet watching Dan's eritrea
have it so we'll see you in the next
video top
[Music]
you